hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar scaling up exosomes and other
extracellular vesicles i'm susie valdez
of labyrinth and i will be your
moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
presented by
lab roots and brought to you by beckmann
culture life
sciences to learn more visit them at
beckman.com
now we encourage you to participate
today by submitting any questions you
might have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free
continuing education credits please
click
on the continuing education window at
the bottom of your screen
to obtain those credits i'd now like to
welcome our speaker dr
derek blintz senior manager biopharma
at beckmann culture life sciences dr lin
welcome you may now begin your
presentation sir
welcome and thank you for joining us
today my name is derek lenz
i'm the senior marketing manager for
biopharma
at beckmann coulter life sciences what
we would like to present to you today
is scaling up and scaling out an
extracellular vesicles
and the use of centrifugation solutions
and managing the quality controls of
these processes
before we get started i'm obliged to
show you
the intellectual property disclaimer
this is uh solely owned by beckmann
coulter incorporated in any use
copyright or distribution without
consent is strictly
so just to introduce the origins of the
field of biopharma
derived from the division of clinical
research in the u.s bureau of medicines
but it's a little more complex than that
because the authority
vested for that is actually held by the
division of bio
pharmaceutics in the united states food
and drug administration
so this is generally to consider the
onset of the field but shortly
thereafter numerous bedrock concepts and
parameters were developed and published
over a range of topics that i cite here
and it's at this point where
protocols for regulatory consideration
and for the scale up and scale out of
biologics also began
by extension however this is also the
point where many of the challenges we
face in scaling up and scaling out are
rooted
so let's talk about some of the key
objectives we'd like to cover today
we'll define the biopharma landscape and
looking at some scale up and scale out
details
looking at the rapid evolution of this
field
we'll then utilize exosomes as a model
for the scale up and scale out of
biologics
and then we're going to highlight i
think a very seminal publication
that really served well to advance the
field of exosomes and other ev research
utilizing centrifugation as a means of
really
isolating pure cultures and scaling them
up from material
research downstream we'll then summarize
conclude and have
a nice discussion in our q a so as i
mentioned
the field of biopharma is a rapid
dynamic field that's been involving very
quickly
since the 1980s when we began research
on genetically modified agricultural
organisms to here in 1990 where we
initiated the human genome project
and we had our first gene therapy
experiment in humans
not seven years later the fda had
started approving
novel biologics in the treatment of
disease indications
as i cite here in 2000
the us venture capital fund for biotech
was estimated to be around 6 billion
and i find this very interesting by 2002
lipitor one of the most successful drugs
to ever be marketed in this case
manufactured by
pfizer had annual sales reaching 8
billion dollars and then lastly
in a matter of 11 short years from 1990
to 2001
we had our first draft sequence of the
human genome project
published in nature and science so a
rapid and dynamically evolving field
that we are in by pharma
so let's switch to this concept of scale
up and scale
out in biologics i use a very generic
workflow here a process where we have
discovery clinical trials and then
commercialization
within those steps there are a number of
key aspects such as
designing the potentially commercially
viable biologics screening it and
finding it
once we find it to select it develop it
tech transfer
or we ultimately want to produce scale
up and
certify so looks a little simple on this
slide but obviously much more complex
now let's use a simple example of
cell cultures in a bioreactor
where we will subsequently harvest
clarify
and isolate our biologic product
of interest when we're talking about
these concepts and scaling options the
first available to us
is scale out usually right increasing
our
capacity to increase our yields
we may then decide to scale up
to increase the throughput so capacity
increase
and throughput increase to ultimately
effect hopefully in a positive manner
operational efficiencies
if we've made the correct selections and
we have run our protocols correctly
so here's some examples of that right if
it's a bioreactor
again we may increase the volume of the
bioreactor to improve capacity
and when we hit our milestones replicate
those
to increase scale up and throughput
on the means to increasing and improving
operational efficiency
now i think most of us that have worked
any amount of time
with biologics appreciate
while this may seem fairly
straightforward
in reality it's rarely a linear scale
game
there are a myriad of nuances
and complexities in biology and
in bio production of biologics uh small
variations such as a material
composition
or bench technique can induce dynamic
magnifying changes and that variability
really causes challenges to us
collectively in the field
so just one simple example to highlight
the complexity and the lack of linearity
in scaling up biologics
i'd like to show the heck 293 cells
more and more becoming popular because
it's uh
it grows quite well in culture
it's it's easily transduced it takes on
transfecting agents quite well
and and it does produce if you're
particularly working with proteins
high quantities of of proteins of
interest
however most of us just assume
certain concentrations of cells
generically right 2 times 10 to the 6 10
to the 7th
i think we've all kind of done that when
we started working with biologics
yet here in an insert cited by the atcc
it recommends keeping densities low
1 to 3 times 10 e5 per ml
concentrations of even 10 e4 per ml when
we're seeding
and in most cases they recommend not to
exceed 10 e6
per ml and i think the picture here on
the right hand side shows that very well
from densities you can see different
morphological and behavioral changes in
these cells right so on the left hand
side of the image
low density the cells look and behave
differently from the image on the right
which is high density we see a lot more
aggregating on the right we see more
dendritic-like
processes being created by the cells the
morphology is changing so
just one simple example of how biologics
are rarely
a linear scale game and this is also the
case
to to further highlight this on the
protein level
we can see for example that cho cells
transfected to produce an igg isotope
molecule do not
behave consistently
depending on your cell cultures there is
an increase
or a differentiation in
post-translational modification patterns
of these proteins
impacted by cell culture conditions so
in this case
looking at cho cells fed glucose
in different manners either bolus fed or
continuous fed
we see a resulting change in the
post-translational modification patterns
those chose cells fed in a batch manner
had greater heterogeneity
in the in in the post-translational
ponification patterns of these igg
isotypes
and it impacted both the pk
and the ability of antibody dependent
cell cytotoxicity mechanisms and what
this group
found was that feeding these cells
in a bowless manner actually caused
greater spikes in ammonia
which resulted in the increased
heterogeneity of these
post-translational modification patterns
of the protein
and the change in their efficacy and
avidity and effectiveness
but by spiking these cultures with
lactate
they were able to restore a more uniform
pattern
in the proteins post-translational
modification patterns and ensuing
functionality
as you saw when you continuously fed it
there are a lot of data on this slide
but you can see that there
was a shift in alanine concentrations
between the two cultures
as well as changes in viable cell
concentration
and again when they spiked these
cultures with
lactate the profile was restored the
heterogeneity was decreased
so what you can see again is just
another example of how
scaling up on these these different
biological workflows is rarely a linear
scale
game now
let's shift gears on let's talk about
exosomes
define them a little bit and then use
them as a model scale up in scale
exosomes and evs are not a new
field of biologic but they're renewed in
interest
in fact one might make the argument it's
one of the original biologics
but i think we were challenged at the
time of really understanding what we're
looking at
because size alone it really is is not a
good
single parameter for differentiating in
general
exosomes are between 30 and 150
nanometers in diameter and this can vary
you'll pick up four different papers and
get four different ranges but
somewhere between 130 to 150 maybe
40 to 200 nanometers they tend to
be excitosed out of the cells
into the extracellular space now this is
in contrast to ectosomes or
shedding micro vesicles now as you see
they have an overlapping size range with
exosomes 100 to a thousand nanometers
but they tend to really bud or bleb off
of the cell membrane
they're not produced in their entirely
internally and then
exocytos like exosomes are now to
further
complicate this with respect to size
range right we have apoptotic bodies
which
of course are very different from
ectosomes or exosomes
but you see here the the potential size
range
of these apoptotic bodies as the cell
goes through programmed cell death
overlaps entirely with the exosomes and
for the most part with the ectosomes
so again size alone while an important
parameter
and necessary is not alone sufficient
and and over the years potential markers
have been cited that could indicate
exosomes and to differentiate them from
say ectosomes or other subcellular
biologics
now just so we're all sort of starting
from the same level playing field
um general considerations for evs
specifically exosomes
again generally membrane bound particles
somewhere between 30 and 150 4200
nanometers
in vivo found in virtually every cell
type and fluid
and they are produced by cells in
culture
typically they contain both proteins and
nucleic acids
more specifically rna the proteins have
been demonstrated to
derive from both cellular sources but
there are also evolutionary
conserved proteins in most cases about
20 000 copies or molecules per exosome
in the case of the rna both messenger
and
and silencing transcripts have been
detected
they serve a myriad of functions both in
vivo and in vitro
in vivo they're used as communication
between
biologics right transferring materials
to different cells
to coordinate behavior to modulate
production
of proteins by affecting targeted genes
and and to induce and coordinate immune
responses
in the case of pathologies right many
cancers have been shown to produce
exosomes to confound or evade
immune system function and or to
hijack resources from the
from the area to to serve those cancer
cells so a myriad of different functions
and this is of course part of the
challenge with
identifying and characterizing these evs
they're sharing these biologics
and and so their their their profiles
tend to be less static maybe than not
so again there are a myriad of details
with respect to functions mechanisms
pathologies we're going to focus on
these exosomes for the remainder of the
talk
now when we set forth to isolate and
purify
exosomes there are a number of common
techniques in the literature that i
cite here um differential
ultracentrifugation
you may do some polymer induced
precipitation like peg
filtration very common of course
antibody purification or affinity
purification typically
by monoclonal antibody and then density
gradient centrifugation
really there are different
benefits conferred or challenges faced
by these techniques
so i don't know if there's necessarily
always a one size fits all
but it is often considered that
differential centrifugation is the gold
standard for
for exosome isolation and purification
this is something cited by
by dr stephen gould who then
cites these techniques and filtrations
to to isolate these
particles here these exosomes that you
see down below
however with this technique there are a
few things that are lacking of course
there's no consideration for example
from differentiating between
let's say viral particle contamination
or something like that so those are the
techniques
but before we really start using
isolation purification
techniques to obtain our exosomes of
interest
we have to understand that there's a
vast heterogeneity here
and what we can choose what i'm
presenting
is a publication from this group looking
at the disparate
isolation methods for extracellular
vesicles and their impact on downstream
rna profiling
they cite four different techniques that
they highlight they either use ultra
centrifugation
uh optiprep for their for their density
gradient technique
they use a kit called exo-quick and
another one called
total exosomal isolation and they look
at the different
techniques and the ability to satisfy
their workflow needs and they summarize
those in this table here and they look
at four
things right so let's start with what
we're focused on
is is purity and and yield and as you
can see here
that while ultra centrifugation did
do a great job with purity and yield
compared to the
isolation kits below optical density
gradient
optiprep centrifugation really did the
best for purity and yield
now the picture's a little bit flipped
here when you see
the the the kits while they did not
purify
and and yield as many exosomes the
ensuing protein
and rna profiles were better with those
kits than
them by centrifugation either either
density or ultra nonetheless for
purity and for yield density gradient
with superiority or all those techniques
and in fact ultra centrifugation
had the most balanced profile here
good on purity good on yields for the
exosomes the protein
and the rna but when it came to exosome
purity in isolation
density gradient was the key and here's
their scoring matrix
now it is also important
when we're working with these biologics
is to control for contamination by
exogenous
sources so let's start with
this more simple protocol before we dive
into this very
i think complex yet
extreme sting publication that i'd like
to present to you
when we're depleting evs centrifugation
can play an effective role and and let's
look at the example of media
purification in this case a fetal bovine
serum
but also applicable to bsa as well so
we're looking here at a commercially
depleted version
of fbs for evs versus
a protocol to deplete these evs in-house
and as a control we're going to use the
unadulterated source of fbs
and as you can see here we're tracking
particle concentrations here is our
standard
the source a fair fairly high
concentration of exogenous evs
that could contaminate and complicate
our downstream use in our ev research
here you can see that the in-house
depletion by ultra centrifugation
was almost as effective as the
commercially depleted version of the fbs
now to evaluate these three different
conditions
what this group did was cultured cells
in vitro for either three or seven days
and then counted viable cells by
automated tripan blue exclusion and
looked at viability
now day three in red day seven in the
gray
and here in the unadulterated control
source
we can see the nominal count of live
cells
interestingly in the ultra centrifuge
depleted fbs we see a profile of cell
viability
very similar to the control
now interestingly uh something about
this commercially depleted version
the process by which they're they're
pulling these evs out
had some sort of effect uh in the cell
culture and by day three the
the viability counts were lower than the
control of the ultra centrifuge
now by day seven um the cell counts the
viability was somewhat restored although
a little lower than
than the control and ultra
centrifugation but nonetheless
this commercially depleted version of
fbs for ev
did cause some variability in the
predicted
cell concentrations the viability of
these cultures
compared to the ultra centrifuge so one
example
i think of of using ultra centrifugation
very simply and effectively
in controlling variability and
maintaining consistency in your uv
work now um
there is a lot of heterogeneity in
biological biopharma protocols in
general and that stands true in the case
of
ultra centrifugation and here we can see
a technique where
where the two were combined uh with
great efficacy
so uh isolating exosomes from jerk cat
cells
via ultra centrifugation a multi-step
process to remove cellular debris
to pellet for the exosomes we used a
biomac and automated biomec to set up
density gradients so that we could
scale up a little of the on the yields
and the purity
and then performed further isolation and
purification
steps so you can see here
there can be a lot of different steps
combinations taken
and it really depends on the biologics
that you're specifically working with
and and the goals of the research and
protocols being used
looking at factors that impact
centrifugation workflows with exosomes
we have these four
main factors here viscosity fluid
density the
k factor right the efficiency of the
rotor and the centrifugation
system time and temperature
now with this study reference here by
moment harabi found is the temperature
and time
really we're not that impactful and
we're really going to focus on
viscosity and k factor or in
in the rest of this discussion so here i
cite
this calculation this formula to to
demonstrate viscosity of liquids
here we can see that
pre and post ultra centrifugation so
dark bars pre
and and lighter bars post we're looking
at
different viscosities and their impact
on isolating micro vessels or or
extracellular vesicles from these
different
materials whether it was plasmid serum
culture media
and as you can see pre and post
prep that this viscosity did have an
impact on yields so let's look a little
further into this okay so here are the
data
showing these uh concentrations pre
and post ultra centrifugation and then
the differences in viscosity
what this study is really arguing is
that the viscosity of the materials
impacts the yield of exosomes or
extracellular vesicles
and that really the lower viscous
solutions
yield greater concentrations of these
micro vesicles
here is the equation for the
sedimentation coefficient they used
and so this really boils down to also
looking at
k factor so the the time for a particle
of sediment through a medium
and that's determined by the maximum
angular velocity
of the centrifuge and the min max radius
of the rotor so
rpms alone are not
a correct measure of the
efficiencies of a centrifugation system
it is this calculation
the k factor that is the true measure of
efficiency
and again what this group concluded was
the viscosities of these different
biofluids
did affect ev isolation the
concentration
and the lower viscous biologics yielded
more evs
and what they also found was a low angle
low angle fixed angle rotor provides
better separation than a swinging bucket
so
another parameter to consider when we're
looking at
isolation and purification of
extracellular vesicles
so now let's look at centrifugation
in the scale-up and scale-up processes
so as i showed you earlier
when we look at the literature when we
talk to our customers when we
when we consider our options for
you have these five techniques here
again right
we're going to ignore filtration for now
uh and and and we're going to ignore
um precipitation uh due to to time
constraints here
and instead we're going to go again with
what dr
gold had cited a number of years back
that differential centrifugation is the
gold standard
well let's put that to the test a little
more huh and let's
let's let's take it a step further and
let's dive into this publication from
moman haravi and colleagues
looking at the clinical utility of evs
and the fact that it will require
standardized
efficient automated methods with
certified standards and controls
in order for this have utility in the
field so again
there are a myriad of different sizes
surface markers inner content function
and physiology
that overlap in these different
subcellular puzzles
and so let's really look at differential
centrifugation as a means of isolating
these evs so
in this case we're going to compare
differential
density in this case using iodicinol
versus an immunoaffinity pulled down
with antibodies
now when it came to density gradient by
iodicinol
what they had used were show cell lines
and compare those to plasmid samples
in this process they further
characterized by these techniques
protein content microscopy sizing and
proteomics
and and here is the process right so
they took they took these these lim863s
released the exosomes um uh
collected also the plasmid and and as
you can see
here um sat these these these materials
out at different
temperatures uh for different amounts of
time
and what what this study really proved
was that
uh temperature maybe is not as impactful
on the integrity of these eaves
as we once thought so diving into this
process
looking at a couple of other cell lines
as well
they isolated the extracellular vesicles
using this protocol here
either through differential
centrifugation and crude pelleting or
density gradient by iodicinol
and comparing that to immunoaffinity
pull down here is what this group
concluded
that in fact the gold standard once upon
a time
alone was maybe a little bit of crude
process for isolating these evs from
both the cell lines and the plasmid
where as the amino affinity pull down
did a quite good job
for for the cell line and did a very
poor job in the plasmid samples and
indeed
they found that density gradient
separation um
had the best yields and purity in both
of those sample types
so they then ran some gels on on
these different bands these density
gradients you see here
from 1.04050608 10 12
14 and what you see here from these gels
is that there were actually um
potentially different subsets or
different expression
patterns in in these different density
layers
and so at this point of the study they
decided to
optimize the density gradient to
to to increase the sensitivity if you
will
by looking at a greater number of
fractions and so
um you see here they they really kind of
broke it down
particularly in the higher levels um to
see if they could
tease out some more distinction between
uh what they saw in those
gels and and and and as you can see here
as they optimized it um different
expression patterns started to reveal
themselves
in these different so uh cell lines in
particular these skn
uh be threes as you show here
and really what they started noticing
was um
a further delineation um
when when when they improved the
sensitivity of the density gradient
so from there they decided to do some
sizing studies looking at these
different fractions
here you see fraction 9
which is 1.08 all the way to 1.18 gram
grams per milliliter and you see uh
different size subpopulations within
this fraction
so it suggested to them and you can see
here from the imaging
that this was not a homogeneous single
population
but perhaps a a a mix
of several different populations
of of ev subtype to
further elucidate the difference in size
in these potential subsets of evs
visual studies were conducted via
electron microscopy
and as you can see here in fraction
seven
we have a subcellular particle in ev
with this sort of morphological profile
right
size is about oh anywhere
around 80 nanometers it looks from the
from the size range and and
and when we compare that to the pelleted
version here you
see uh a lot of variability in the size
a much larger size and
at least from my perspective it looks
like a a cell membrane that maybe is
under a little duress and
and showing some folding and some
atypical
uh um profiles perhaps due to the the
physical forces
by density gradient now compare that
fraction
seven in the upper left hand corner
via density gradient to this fraction
910
and visually clearly
we see two morphologically different
populations here
the population here on the right is
seems to be of larger size it's
um greater than 100 nanometers or more
we see
maybe a little bit of a difference in in
in the profile of the membrane
and again to highlight that if if we
show differential
centrifugation down here or dense uh
ultracentrifugation rather
morphology so indeed by electron
microscopy
we have now two different
size populations by the dulcimax and
here we can see by
electron microscopy two morphologically
different
subpopulations so to further
elucidate what they were looking at
so what the group did is they looked at
various rab gt paces so these
are intracellular switches that control
the accessibility of these different evs
to the compartments of cells and as you
can see here
when we're looking at this exosome
versus what they're now calling
potentially ectisone group
certain rap gtp aces are exclusively
detected in exosomes as shown here on
the left
conversely these other ones here on the
far right are exclusively detected in
the ectasm
so further showing differences in these
internal
switch and communication mechanisms i
think there's well over 60
of them associated uh with this process
with with extracellular vesicles so
again some exclusively detected in the
exosome population only whereas others
in the ectosome
and then in the middle you see kind of a
a more heterogeneous where
some are expressed in both or or or
slightly expressed in both
but nonetheless two distinct rab gt
paces uh become revealed when we look at
these two different
subtypes of evs
now this to me is an extremely
impressive
uh summary slide when you look at all of
the work
involved in monitoring these myriad of
regulatory processes or biological
processes here
from from cell proliferation metabolism
looking at the affected change
in these biological processes um in the
presence
of enriched or depleted exosomes
and ectosomes and as you can see
furthermore
in this depleted group we have this huge
decrease in
in in regulatory regulation of
translation cell metabolism and
proliferation
apoptosis protein folding and some other
things
or in contrast in that enriched
population
we see increases in immune system
responses cell cell
signaling fatty acid metabolism protein
transport
and other signaling pathways so
definitely showing this this distinct
change in the biological processes
as to whether the the materials are
enriched or depleted
for exosomes and ectosomes so really
what this group
i think showed was
by optimizing their density gradient
protocols they were able to further
isolate
purify and then subsequently
characterize
potentially two distinct subtypes within
this
extracellular exosome subpopulation
right we have this
fraction seven which are these small
exosomes that um are
are fairly consistent in size most of
them fall within
the 30 to 150 nanometer range and as we
saw
earlier in the talk they affect
uh different changes in biological
processes there
of different morphology as well by
electron
microscopy in contrast this more dense
fraction
fraction 9 these
large evs or ectosomes
are more heterogeneous in size
although more than half of them are this
larger 150 to 500 nanometer size
and they may be morphologically
physiologically
functionally distinct uh from this
fraction seven these smaller exosomes
um and again without them being able to
use density gradient ultracentrifugation
and really
optimize their platform their their
protocols to their needs
the study may not have been so by taking
advantage
of the unique ability uh capabilities of
density gradient ultra centrifugation to
really
further isolate and purify
their subpopulations which then allowed
them to characterize them by size
and functionality from these results
using these three different cell lines
they proposed two distinct sets of
markers to differentiate exosomes
from ectosomes and you can see these
these gels here in the middle but on the
left hand side are the markers they
propose for exosomes
and on the right hand side for ectosomes
something again would not be possible
without a technique that could really
allow them to isolate
and purify their target population of
evs
now one area again getting back to scale
up
and scale out is in the production of
these
density gradient layers right so i think
a lot of us are in the lab where
uh the one there's one individual who's
really good at layering these densities
and she or he happens to be on vacation
for two weeks
uh you know what do we do it can be
challenging so there are
platforms there are techniques where we
can completely automate
the density gradient layering thereby
helping
address the throughput right the scale
up
component of scaling up and scaling out
on extracellular vesicles
there really is no point to scaling up
and scaling out
until we have a well-defined
well-characterized
target and that we have a protocol
that thoroughly isolates and separates
the part
the the the population of interest from
those of non-interest
so uh again until we know what our
target is it's very difficult to scale
up and scale out
and as you saw earlier in the
conversation uh biologics is very
a linear scale game so if we want a
technique that could really do a good
job isolating and characterizing
the density layering gradient can be
automated using our
biomac automated system and from there
we can perhaps propose
a protocol that may get us towards where
our goal is and that is what moment
harami and colleagues said until we have
consistent
known described processes
with controls in place it's going to be
challenging
to scale up and evolve evs exosomes and
other subcellular biologics so here's an
example of what this group proposed
as a means of separating exosomes from
ectosomes
on our studies so in summary
in centrifugation workflows for exosome
isolation much of what defines evs and
exosomes really still is in flux right
we know size alone is is is necessary
but not sufficient
because of the overlap in size with
other subcellular particles
and there really still is no consensus
on what the definition of these
particles are
so without basic characterization other
aspects are
are going to continue to remain uh
poorly defined i think
and so again through a combination of
ultra centrifugation more specifically
density separation this is shown
to be highly effective means in ev scale
up and scale out
we can work with larger amounts of high
purity samples
and have more consistent and predictable
outcomes from our workflows
which i think is an important key to
the next chapter in evolving the field
of extracellular vesicles exosomes and
now ectosomes
and so with that i really would like to
thank you for your time and attention
my contact information my email is here
below
and i'm happy to entertain any questions
comments or discussions that the
audience might like to have right now
so again thank you
and thank you dr lent for that
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
and if you have any questions you'd like
to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen and we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for
so it looks like we already have some
great questions
coming in from our audience derek our
first question
is eevee isolation its
subtypes is truly becoming too
challenging
and through a pure and though appear
very important to cellular processes
hard to to get traction in adopting
ev research
yes this is a a very challenging topic
and i think rajesh thank you for
for the comments and the questions i
don't disagree with you
um when things are difficult like this i
like to be reminded of what my mentor
said if it would be
it was easy would be done already and
they wouldn't need us so
so we have this challenge in front of us
and i think originally as i mentioned
size alone was an insufficient parameter
and
and now we're seeing as more details
become available the picture becomes
more challenging right particularly
since these biologic materials are being
shared and transferred and effector
functions enacted so
certainly it's going to be a assumation
of of characteristics we're going to
have to look at
size obviously i think that the first
logical place to look at is the
evolutionarily conserved
uh markers and proteins and and perhaps
looking at
at something we can delineate akin to
lymphocytes right
multiple markers for example to discern
uh cd4 from cda t cells and other
lymphocytes
it is difficult to get traction and and
so i'm going to go back to the statement
that we we really as a collective group
need to start deciding on
standardized practices controls
and and and known standards to to get at
this challenge but
i i do share um your pain there rajesh
and it's a good point to bring up
uh nonetheless there's a tremendous
amount
of potential clinical and application
potential with these evs so i think it's
certainly worth
continuing to to fight and get this
figured out
thank you so much derek now our next
question is
given there's an overlap in size and
density profiles for exosomes and other
evs
are there specific techniques to confirm
the precise isolation and
characterization
of exosomes before their use in
therapeutic
development again that's a great
question i think that gets at the crux
of another important aspect in this
field
i think like most biologics right we we
have to take advantage of orthogonal
techniques to verify
what we're looking at of course so
something like dynamic light scattering
uh could be helpful for determining size
profile
the challenge here i think uh
christy and this is a good point you
bring up is again the overlap in size
with these different subsets and and
what that i think does sometimes
is inadvertently gets us to the limits
of sensitivity for certain techniques
for example um coulter principle right a
non-labeling direct manner of sizing
particles like cells very effective
until we start getting down to around
220 nanometers then we have some
challenges with
with resolution um i haven't seen
a tremendous amount of research here yet
but i'm going to make a leap
and an analytical ultra centrifugation
something that's been used very
effectively for
viral vectors and more recently lipid
nanoparticles could be a really good
orthogonal technique for determining
not only the size of the particles but
also
the uh the payload the inner contents of
the material
but as it stands right now precise
isolation and characterization
from what i can tell is where many of us
need to focus
and really discern these methods before
we can move on and scale up
but christy i'd be happy to talk with
you offline if you wanted to have a
conversation
thank you so much our next question have
exosomes been isolated from plants
these are by the way this very engaged
audience appreciate all the
questions and comments um
i like to hear talks but this is my
favorite part right having a discussion
and trying to educate one another on on
the state of the field
yes from what i can tell and i i'm not a
botanist but i have seen
some publications where there are
isolating maybe not exosomes but let's
call them evs from plants
um so certainly there there is the the
possibility that that biologic is
present in in that type of organism
good question thank you and i also
want to thank our audience for these
great questions coming in
how about using ion exchange
chromatography
to enrich evs before further ultra
centrifuge
isolation yep this is this is a common
conversation and again
i think it's very important to cite we
we all want to find that
that silver bullet that magic technique
i i don't
think that that there is such a thing
right
so um looking at these these other
techniques
um such as ion exchange chromatography
it really depends what you want for
trade-offs so you can
you can process high volumes of course
with chromatography but
the challenges i've had conveyed to me
from customers and other researchers
uh friends of mine in the field is that
you can you
lose a lot of the yield and the clumping
in these columns and so
you'll be able to trade off right
process high volumes
it's just that the the yields the roi
may not be
uh sufficient for your downstream needs
so um
it's important to look at these
different techniques and and to
understand the trade-offs
and determine what's going to be best
for your specific needs
so if i was looking for high purity high
yield ion exchange chromatography
might be counterproductive but if i had
huge volumes
and that i wanted to process quickly i
might keep that as an option
good question thank you derek now derek
do
exodus sums in other play a role in
disease
pathogenesis or are they merely a marker
of disease
christie you are asking great questions
today all of you are
um yes there does seem to be the case
in both instances now let's let's talk
about the disease pathogenesis
uh specifically cancer we have observed
extracellular vesicles being released by
the cancer cell
to impact signaling
and local biogenesis we've seen examples
of
materials being released so that the
cancer cells can hijack the vasculature
right get a greater blood flow oxygen
flow and more nutrients to it
we've seen examples of cancer cells
releasing evs
to evade and confound the immune system
but also to your point in in other cases
we we can see these evs as
indicators for disease so i
think the literature points to to both
these situations and it really just
depends on
on on the disease indicator of interest
thank you now derek how does this
harvesting exosome pave
way to cancer research yep
great question john and and good timing
right let's follow up on that
if we are able to have more consistent
predictable techniques for isolation and
purification
then obviously by logic that that
impacts positively all your downstream
research
it could be the case i'm hypothetical
here
that we may be looking at two different
distinct populations of exosomes
and one may be cancer derived and one
baby non-cancer derived or they may be
two different
subsets of of of exosomes or evs coming
from the cancer cells that ultimately
affect different functions but i think
really i i bait and switch this talk a
little i'll admit right
we wanted to talk about scale up and
scale out but the point
is since biologics is rarely a linear
scale game we really need to double down
on our isolation and purification
before we take that next big step i hope
that answers your question if it doesn't
please let me know
we can continue the conversation offline
now we have time for a few more
questions derek
do you think it's possible to isolate
exosomes
from exosomes based on ultra
filtration steps downstream of
chromatography
certainly possible and thank you fatima
for the question
the the concern here i think when i look
at the data in the literature
is the physical forces and they're
ensuing negative impact on the
morphological profile of our target
biologic
so i think you saw in the case of the
pictures from electron microscopy
that the differential centrifugation
compared to density gradient the the
materials looked a little different
right again and
from from my take the density gradient
uh evs looked a little more true to
expectation whereas
when we subjected it to differential and
those high physical forces
centrifugal forces and g-forces it
seemed like
the cell lost the uh the material lost a
little bit of its integrity
so my concern here is we do
chromatography
we may lose a lot of our materials and
then we we subject it to alter
filtration
the question becomes how much and what
are the quality of what you have left
over
the literature suggests to me instead
that we optimize density gradient
centrifugation and and perhaps
understand the markers associated with
those targets
and then move in another direction maybe
we do density gradient and then from
there
immunoaffinity a pull down for example
but great question thank you so much now
you mentioned k-factor for
centrifugation
for efficiency or something similar
could you review that a little bit more
absolutely um this this comes up quite a
bit
um now once upon a time as a young
scientist i was guilty of this as well
right we have to we have too much on our
plate
and and we have to know a little bit
about everything i think there
is a an assumed mistake when we're
evaluating our centrifugation protocols
that
the uh that the rpms
are alone the single
parameter for deciding the efficiencies
when when that is indeed not the case
the true
measure of efficiency in a
centrifugation
protocol is is the k factor and the k
factor takes a couple of variables
um into consideration now it doesn't
take temperature into consideration
but it's the maximum speed as well as
the uh path length that the particle
travels within the the the the tube or
the container it's being held in
and and so those factors together equal
the k
factor generally what it suggests is the
lower the k
factor the shorter the run time so rpm
alone
is not sufficient we have to consider
the path length that the particle
travels
and those factors together are referred
to as k
factor and that is the true measure of
efficiency but
great question i'm always happy to have
that discussion
thank you so much now our next audience
member
says we're having some trouble with
consistently
determining content of our exosome
exosome particles could you suggest an
analytical
technique for particle payload
yup this is a good question and i think
something that we're always
kind of wrestling with in the back of
our research minds
there are other orthogonal techniques we
can look at for example we could we
could use dynamic light scattering to
further separate by size
but when it comes to that particle
payload
there is not a lot of literature out
there yet
but i i would be surprised if the
technique of analytical
ultracentrifugation
can do for extracellular vesicles what
it's been doing for viral vectors and
more recently for lipid nanoparticles
where we're using separation plus
interrogation either by uv vis
spectrometry or or in in parallel with
rayleigh
interference we can really discern
how much content is inside that particle
by its separation techniques
you can see this with genomic payload
for aav
and gene therapy for example so in my
mind
analytical ultra centrifugation uh could
be an extremely powerful technique not
only for that parameter
but also for size and and ultimately
other orthogonal techniques so
good question thank you derek we have
time for one more question
our audience member says if i were to
use flow cytometry for easy analysis
analyses would you also recommend adding
treacherous bannon cd63
and second part of the question also if
i wanted to analyze
internal contents could you recommend a
fixing
and staining protocols well okay so
there's there's a lot in this question
let me see if i can get through it and
the time left first of all
we have to be cautious i'll cite earlier
what i said the the the limits of
resolution for size on some of these
techniques
um look at the flow cytometer that
you're using right some of them
beckman for example can can look fairly
well below
cellular but will not
be able to measure the full range of
sizes
of potential for ev so so that's one
challenge
um from what i can read from what i see
right the tetraspanning is is typically
kind of a
a pan ev marker and and so again i think
what's going to happen
ultimately is something akin to what we
see with lymphocyte analysis right
something i'm extremely
familiar with looking at multiple
markers distinguish
maybe cd4s from cd8s and then memory cd4
from from from naive activated so on and
so forth
um as far as a fixing and stating
protocol
that's a tough one i've had a lot of
experience there
in in some cases you know fixing with
paraformaldehyde and doing uh
proliferation essays on
on cells is no problem but um
before i answer that question i'm gonna
have to look into the literature a
little bit more because there's a lot of
variability
in the lipid profiles of these different
particles as well
so i i wish i could answer that in its
entirety but i want to provide anything
that i'm not 100
certain on derek i want to thank you
again for your
time today and for your important
research would you like to provide any
closing remarks before we go uh
absolutely i'd like to thank you know
your group to start off with your your
absolutely wonderful work with
um thank you to the audience i i hope it
was time well spent
seem very engaged we appreciate all the
questions
and please if you want to continue any
conversations or have further
discussions
do not hesitate to reach out but thanks
and enjoy the rest of your day
and thank you sir for your presentation
and we would also like to thank
lab roots and our sponsor beckman
culture life sciences for underwriting
today's educational webcast
and before we go i want to thank our
audience for joining us today
and further interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed
by our speaker via contact information
you provided at the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
laboratory will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's
live event until next time take care
everyone
bye